the president and top intelligence
committee Democrat Adam Schiff or firing
social media bombs at one another over
the surveillance memos this comes as
President Trump tries to put pressure on
Democrats over immigration and another
fast approaching deadline for a
government shutdown chief White House
correspondent John Roberts has all of
that for us tonight from the North Lawn
good evening John Franken evening to you
arriving back at the White House from
Cincinnati a short time ago the
president ignored shouted questions
about the FISA memo that's four times
now that he's ignored such questions he
also ignore questions about the stock
market but on social media and in his
speech today the President had plenty to
say about that Pfizer memo promoting tax
reform in Cincinnati President Trump
didn't specifically mention the
Republican FISA memo but it was clear
what he was talking about oh but did we
catch them in the act or what you know
what I'm done oh did we catch them in
the act
they are very embarrassed they never
thought they were he to get caught we
caught him hey we caught a lot so much
fun for like the great sleuth on Twitter
earlier the president praised
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez as a man of tremendous courage a
great American hero for making the memo
public and he took sharp aim at the
ranking Democrat on the committee
writing little Adam Schiff who is
desperate to run for higher office is
one of the biggest liars and leakers in
Washington right up there with Comey
Warner Brennan and clapper Adam leaves
close committee hearings to illegally
leak confidential information must be
stopped
Schiff wasn't about to let that go
unanswered tweeting back mr. president I
see you've had a busy morning of
executive time instead of tweeting false
smears the American people would
appreciate if you turned off the TV and
help solve the funding crisis protected
dreamers or really anything else
President Trump did take some time to
focus on something else
tax reform not mentioning the huge drop
in the stock market despite taking
credit for its rise but bragging on the
growth potential of his tax reform plan
who can work hard but if you don't have
the right leader setting the right tone
in all fairness aying I am non
braggadocious
but if I don't set a tone like you're
not gonna keep taking our jobs
you're not gonna keep doing what you're
doing for the first time today President
Trump said because of tax reform
Republicans may buck historic trends in
the November midterms but I think
because of what we've done because of
the tremendous success we've had I have
a feeling that we're going to do
incredibly well in 18 and and I have to
say this history is not on our side but
it's not because of that word
complacency President Trump also wants
to make sure he doesn't take the blame
if there's no deal on daca with the
deadline now just a month away the
president tweeting this morning any deal
on daca that does not include strong
border security and the desperately
needed wall is a total waste of time
March 5th is rapidly approaching and the
DEM seemed not to care about daca make a
deal and the president again took aim at
Nancy Pelosi suggesting her criticism of
tax cuts amounting to crumbs makes it
difficult for him to work with her there
are a lot of people that want to run her
out she's she's really out there I'm
supposed to make a deal with her and
president Trump took another shot at
Democrats who sat on their hands during
his speech to the state in the State of
the Union address at Capitol Hill last
Tuesday saying that they were like death
on American and that not applauding
things like historically low black
unemployment amounted to treason Brett
John Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thank you